Bad Bunny seemingly takes Kendall Jenner
on a wild ride through the Coachella
fairgrounds in California like oh my God
just be cool it's fine this comes after
she was spotted supporting him on Friday
after he made history becoming the first
Latino solo artist who headlined the
festival
I always put a piece of my heart on
everything that I do music yeah the
reality star was caught dancing to his
music in multiple videos circulating
online
it's really exciting adding fuel to the
romance rumors
it's not always easy but I don't know I
just kind of I like to keep my private
life pretty private so I try my best but
at the same time I don't I don't like to
let being seen out in public with
someone like affect my everyday life and
Kenny is sticking to that following the
model split from NBA star Devin Booker
last year and the rapper Calling it
Quits with longtime girlfriend Gabriella
Berlin Gary Kendall and Bad Bunny
haven't shied away from showing each
other love I always be my myself in
April the two were spotted enjoying a
romantic horseback ride a hobby Kendall
knows a lot about Kendall if this
modeling thing doesn't work out you
could be a horseback rider like a real
Pro your commentary is insane and in
March they shared a hug and a kiss after
a sushi date in Los Angeles with a
source revealing to ET in February that
the two were quote attracted to each
other and have a flirty Vibe adding
quote is still new but they're enjoying
each other's company and like each other
goodbye uh
uh happiness nothing anything
complicated while Kendall and Bad Bunny
haven't tried to hide their budding
romance it's unlikely to see any of it
play out on season three of the
Kardashians I think like a cool part
about Kylie and I growing up on the show
um and something that maybe we don't
take for granted is you know we got to
see things happen before we got you know
older our older sisters kind of
experienced a life that we got to view
and so just from a really young age I
think both Kylie and I kind of knew what
we wanted to keep off the show or what
we wanted to keep to ourselves and um
yeah I think that it's kind of as simple
as that
[Music]
thank you